I love Michael's like so much I think
it's hysterical that that's like your
favorite celebrity to me she's just he's
an angel
he really had blesses us with his voice
one day I'll beat it though good eye how
are you this is uh honestly probably the
greatest day of my life
[Music]
[Music]
happy-sad hopeful seems like there's a
romantic musical tonic for every mood
but why do we listen to love songs is it
just because they make us feel better or
it's because we're all desperately
trying to find something that captures
the magic of the real thing Josephine we
were 15 she live in Sweden I lived in
Thailand and every night we talk and one
Valentine's Day I wrote her a love song
like if it's my more vocally inclined
friends jam to sing it for her but ever
since then I've always wanted to
recapture that feeling so now despite
having no singing ability whatsoever I'm
going to write another love song and I
know just the person to help me with it
the other favorite Michael Buble song do
you guys like Michael Buble I'm gonna
send you a boob lady shirt and I promise
few kids that I give so much more than I
get
top five reasons why I love Michael
Buble one his songs are the embodiment
of joy to his work captures that
timeless magic of great music three
he sings songs about Christmas greatest
time of the year for happy sad whatever
my mood I can always kind of sum Buble
to make me feel better and five well he
has the voice of a goddamn angel
[Music]
so Michael Buble is in that room right
now feet away and in a few moments I
will be writing a song with my idol
the Canadian treasure himself and why
may seem very calm on the outside hate
to say on the inside my stomach is
eating itself
I just really hope I don't cry I just
want you guys to all know I believe in
all of you and together if we just try
our very best we could
[Music]
hey there you are
wow we made it work Josephine I I don't
even know where to begin
on the day that I've had so you know me
better than most people who's the one
person I could meet that would blow my
mind it's so nice to meet you nice to
know what a way to meet you that's you
know we got know each other very well
I don't know scale 0 million how do you
say over a million in Swedish or a
million this is a hands dish my mother
has ditched this for you know well
either that or she bought at the market
in Laos but what are the other I'm
stoked for you oh look at that
screw this flower yeah that's gonna go
right there oh look at us together soon
and
coming back to me is against our it's a
chance we didn't just sing cheesy love
songs together we wrote a love song
together so I'm here today to well
basically to have your expertise and
helping me write a love song in 15
minutes 15 pieces in 15 minutes really
really I'm gonna let you take the lead
on what do you mean you're gonna let me
take the lead you are oh no my name is
not aria it's Michael
your parents think you are yeah dude
they set you up for this moment what was
it about uh why don't we start with
something that you love what's your
favorite food I love sushi what are your
favorite pieces of sushi I love salmon
tamago egg I love a good rainbow roll
the song is comparing the feeling of
love to my love for sushi do you know
you love sushi
I know Oh
[Music]
every every time you couldn't go I'd get
the scent of time no so you can try
Tomiko and come and go why can't you
because it doesn't work you thought to
you that's I don't like the soft rhymes
you know I could see like the the cogs
in his head turning I get the scent I
get the scent of tuna roll let's and
that's like what we'll do is here we'll
start syncopating words it really was
like watching like a master at work oh
no I got it better you like my rainbow
roll chop scallop : I'll never let you
go
Catholic that I can't let go that just
works word wise better I hope you were
cheap but make them think oh we just
said something nasty about her but now
we flip it and we go I hope you were
cheap hmm and then you go no I meant the
bill is cheap we are gonna go back to
Phil Collins land there's a song that he
wrote called sue CBO so we're gonna use
Sussudio and we're gonna rhyme it with
time ago and that's gonna be our course
and then you know what people will say
like what does that mean and we'll go we
means whatever you want it to mean and
only you and I will really know a bang
okay I sense hit song just shoot time
ago gander I hope you know how you rock
my it was honestly the greatest 30
minutes of my life
I think it's all downhill from here
honestly wow if no one's clapping what
the what clapping Wow like what happens
now with the song and everything okay so
10 years ago I was too afraid of seeing
the love song I wrote for Josephine but
now here we are at else it's open mic
night I mean it sing the song I wrote
with Michael Buble his life's too short
not to do the things that scare you so
let's do this
[Applause]
[Music]
and this is played Monday lousy nervous
I don't I don't sing so this is it's
gonna be something I've been rehearsing
non-stop at home sorting the song out on
the keys on the guitar finishing up that
second verse I guess we'll just see how
it goes give a round of applause to this
beautiful man behind me I'm gonna let
him introduce himself all right yeah so
my name is my name is aria this is the
first-ever performance of Buble and in
tubble original and as a heads up I am
NOT a singer but I guess than that I am
all right bear with me thank you I
really appreciate the patience all right
well hardly but thank you
[Music]
I get the scent
[Music]
it's always sweet just like a sweet with
solid Street I hope your truth
cecelio
[Applause]
[Music]
what makes a great love song feelings
you're putting the feelings and the
experiences that you've had and trying
to honestly is there a person that you
have in mind you know I'd like I'd like
to think there is or at least you know
the idea of someone I hope she
appreciates it when it comes to love I
mean there's no bigger feeling than that
right
like whatever comes in spectrum if
you're in love or heartbroken or have a
crush I think love is one of the biggest
feelings you could ever have so what a
better outlook them to seeing it right
[Music]
[Music]
honestly I think the reason why we
listen to love songs is because it
doesn't really matter if it's good or
bad silly or heartfelt we all listen to
love songs because when we do we're
always thinking about someone so I guess
the only real question is when you
listen to a love song where are you
thinking about
Sussudio telleth
I hope you know
how Europe my Sunil
tell ago I hope you
[Music]